de commencer parce que nous avons une
matinée fort chargée au niveau de notre
commission puisqu'à 10h30 nous avons
l'audition du PDG de DF monsieur Luc
Raymond je sais qu'il y a encore un
certain nombre de nos collègues qui vont
bien évidemment nous rejoindre certains
d'entre eux participer au petit-
dééjeuner de la FNSEA nous les avons
quitté
prématurément mais je pense qu'ils vont
nous rejoindre dans le cours de
l'audition donc nous auditionnons ce
matin madame la secrétaire d'État chargé
de la citoyenneté et de la ville auprès
du ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outresmers et auprès du ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la secrétaire
d'État nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir bien évidemment pour la
première fois dans le cadre de cette
commission puisque vous avez été tout
récemment nommé secrétaire d'État et que
juste dans le mandat précédent enfin
dans votre success votre préd cesseur
lui cumuler à la fois le logement et la
politique de la ville là il y a eu une
une volonté de scinder la politique de
la ville rattaché au ministère de
l'Intérieur et le logement rattaché à la
transition écologique ministère auquel
vous êtes également rattaché donc cette
audition est diffusée en vidéo en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat et elle
sera disponible ensuite à la demande
donc vous avez la responsabilité madame
la ministre d'une politique qui est plus
que jamais au cœur de l'actualité depuis
les émeutes en juin dernier une
politique dont l'importance ne date
cependant pas du mois de juin car elle a
toujours été depuis la création de ce
ministère au cœur du vivre ensemble au
sein des communautés urbaines il n'est
peut-être pas inutile de rappeler que
dans une certaine mesure vous incarnez
la politique que vous devez mettre en
œuvre vous êtes né à Marseille dans une
famille N nombreuse issue de
l'immigration algérienne vous avez vécu
dans une cité avant de travailler dans
la production audiovisuel jusqu'à
devenir chef d'entreprise vous vous êtes
ensuite investi en politique devenant
conseillère régional de la région sud
provovence Alpe Côte d'Azur que je
connais bien puis député de Marseille en
2022 et enfin ministre depuis le mois de
juillet
2023 vous nous présentez donc ce matin
un budget s'inscrivant dans la
continuité de la hausse constatée ces
dernières années la dotation du
programme 147 qui est le programme dédié
à la politique de la ville est en
progression de 6,2 % pour
2024 soit 37 millions d'euros de plus
cette évolution s'explique par la hausse
de 35 millions d'euros du versement de
l'État à l'Agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine l'an rue en revanche
l'extension des cités éducatives budgeté
à hauteur de 28 millions d'euros se
réalisera grâce à des économies
notamment au travers de l'arrêt des
bataillons de la prévention en réalité
donc je perd ma page or en rue et compte
tenu de l'inflation les moyens
d'intervention de la politique de la
ville vont baisser cela interpelle tant
les années je le disais en préambule
2023 et surtout 2024 à venir en tout cas
apparaissent comme un tournant pour la
politique de la ville et ce au moins
sous quatre aspects tout d'abord deux
évolutions majeures sont attendues en
2024 l'entrée en vigueur de la nouvelle
géographie prioritaire et la signature
en métropole des nouveaux contrats de
ville pour la période
2024-2030 ensuite le nouveau programme
de renouvellement urbain
npnru est désormais dans sa phase
opérationnelle avec des déca
qui s'élève à près de 1 milliard d'euros
par an l'état sera-t-il à la hauteur et
les besoins de financement de l'enrue ne
risque-t-il pas de fagociter les moyens
de la politique de la ville enfin Madame
la Ministre la trajectoire budgétaire
pour
2024 contraste également avec le
caractère exceptionnel des émeutes
urbaines que nous avons connu au début
de l'été et auquel le gouvernement a
répondu en tout cas c'est ce que nous
pensons tardivement par les annonces des
26 et 27 octobre derniers et dont la
traduction n'est que partielle dans le
budget au-delà de la seule réponse
budgétaire notre commission serait très
intéressée avec l'expérience qui est la
vôtre de connaître votre propre analyse
des émeutes nous souhaiterions également
savoir quelle réponse vous apportez à la
mise en accusation je dirais récurrente
de la politique de la ville et du
renouvellement urbain à laquelle ces
violences ont donné est lieu ce serait
d'autant plus intéressant pour nous que
le comité interministériel des villes le
CIV qui s'est tenu je le disais tout
récemment le vendredi 27 octobre après
tout de même quatre reports et plus d'un
an d'attente a repris nombre de
propositions de notre commission ainsi
c'est bien notre commission qui a obtenu
en CMP de faire figurer dans la loi 3DS
dans un rapport je le dis de force avec
le gouvernement j'en a été le rapporteur
la notion de résidence à enjeu de mixité
sociale pour éviter la concentration des
difficultés or la loi a été publiée il y
a plus de 18 mois que de temps perdu la
publication du décret annoncé par la
première ministre n'est toujours pas
effective le CIP le CIV pardon reprend
également nombre des mesures du rapport
que nous avons publié avec notre
collègue Valérie lettard qui n'est plus
parmi nous et Viviane Artigalas que je
salue à l'été 2022 tel dans ce Rapp
rapport nous soulignons le soutien aux
associations le développement de
l'entrepreneuriat ou encore la réforme
des conseils citoyens mais comme ce
rapport contient encore beaucoup
d'autres propositions qui mériteraient
d'être reprises dans un prochain CIV et
notamment je pense plus particulièrement
à l'entrepreneuriat féminin je me
permets de vous remettre un exemplaire
de ce rapport que nous avons fait donc
toutes les trois et qui j'espère
deviendra votre livre de chevet pour que
vous puissiez continuer à vous saisir
des propositions que nous avons formulé
dans ce rapport enfin je relève le
souhait du CIV de renforcer le rôle du
maire dans l'attribution des logements
sociaux que vous proposez de réaliser
sous forme de circulaire ce qui me
paraît juridiquement impossible je
voudrais donc vous signaler mais vous le
savez certainement que le Sénat a voté
dès la reprise de nos travaux
parlementaires et transmis à l'Assemblée
nationale le 10 octobre dernier une
proposition de loi déposée en avril par
notre collègue Sophie primar sur ce
sujet et qui pourrait me semble-t-il
être utilement reprise par le
gouvernement madame la ministre vous
trouverez donc dans notre commission une
force de proposition et d'action
s'appuyant sur l'expérience des
territoires que nous incarnons dans leur
diversité et les sensibilités de chacun
des membres de cette commission nous
avons conscience que la politique de la
ville n'est pas une baguette magique
mais doit être le fruit d'une stratégie
cohérente de long terme qui seule nous
semble-t-il peut apporter des résultats
je vous laisse maintenant madame la
ministre présenter votre budget pour
2024 répondre à toute ou partie des
questions que je viens de vous poser
ensuite je donnerai la parole à notre
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
Viviane articalas qui est rapporteur
pour avis de la mission politique de la
ville qui connaît bien évidemment très
bien ses sujets et ensuite j'ouvrirai
les questions à l'ensemble de nos
collègu madame la ministre c'est à VOUS
mer merci beaucoup bonjour à tous donc
merci infiniment Dominique pour votre
accueil madame la présidente
dominiqueasson Madame la rapporteur pour
avis Vivian Artigalas mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est pour moi
un honneur d'être auditionné aujourd'hui
et pour la première fois devant votre
commission à l'occasion de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances pour
2024 comme vous le savez le programme
147 politique de la ville porte les
crédits spécifiques dédiés comme son nom
l'indique à la politique de la ville que
je connais donc j'ai la responsabilité
depuis le 20 juillet 2023 dans le cadre
du projet de loi de finances pour 2024
la priorité est donnée à la
stabilisation des crédits locaux
notamment pour permettre le financement
de la nouvelle génération des contrats
de ville en 2024 ce sont ainsi 636
millions d'euros qui seront dédiés à la
politique de la ville soit une hausse de
près de 40 millions d'euros par rapport
à 2023 elle permettra de financer la
généralisation des cités éducatives vous
en avez parlé la jeunesse et et
l'éducation étant au cœur de mes
préoccupations elle permettra également
d'augmenter la participation de l'État
concernant la rénovation urbaine via
l'en rue concernant les bataillons de la
prévention le projet annuel indique la
fin de leur financement comme cela a été
prévu lors de la mise en place de ce
dispositif cependant au regard des
événements du mois de juin dernier sur
lesquels nous reviendrons certainement
il semble et il me semble nécessaire de
prolonger certains bataillons j'ai donc
obtenu 20 millions d'euros de gel pour
permettre notamment leur financement dès
cette année pour l'année
2024 pour 2027 pour 2025 pardon cette
question sera traitée en lien avec la
réforme du dispositif des adultes relais
que je souhaite porter comme vous le
savez le programme 147 ne représente pas
la totalité des crédits affectés au
quartiers politique de la ville et la
priorité doit d'ailleurs être donnée à
la mobilisation des dispositifs de droit
commun mais ces crédits doivent jouer un
effet levier et compléter les dispositif
de droits commun afin d'améliorer la
territorialisation de nos politiques de
favoriser les synergies de développer
les actions à caractère innovant et les
adaptations nécessaires aux spécificités
de ces territoires j'insiste devant vous
il me semble que la mobilisation du
droit commun est prioritaire et son
évaluation un véritable enjeu je l'avais
dit plus haut le document de politique
transversale dpt ville qui accompagne
chaque loi de finances doit normalement
jouer ce rôle mais ces modalités de
construction aujourd'hui ne permettent
pas d'avoir une vue précise à la maille
de chaque quartier l'amélioration de
l'évaluation de ces crédits est un
travail que je mène avec l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement le Parlement a
par ailleurs selon moi un rôle important
à jouer dans cette évaluation on parle
du droit commun cette mobilisation du
droit commun s'inscrit bien sûr dans la
droite ligne du Conseil interministériel
des villes qui s'est tenu le 27 octobre
dernier et dont je suivrai la mise en
uvre avec beaucoup d'attention parmi les
mesures que je veux devant vous
souligner on peut citer la mobilisation
de 15 % du fond vert pour les quartiers
prioritaires le déploiement du programme
quartier 2030 entrepreneuriat
l'ouverture des collèges de 8h à 18h ou
encore le rapprochement des zonages
quartier prioritaires REP et REP plus
les différentes mesures ont été
concertées en amont avec les élus et
association d'élus avec les les acteurs
associatifs mais aussi avec les services
de l'état déconcentré pour apporter les
réponses les plus adaptées aux besoins
de ces territoires et de leurs habitants
cette concertation a ainsi permis
l'inscription de nouvelles mesures mais
aussi l'adaptation de mesures envisagées
par le gouvernement par ailleurs je
relancerai les conventions
interministérielles d'objectifs qui
comprendront des objectifs quantifiables
et des indicateurs permettant leur suivi
je souhaite également que celle-ci soit
déclinée au niveau local pour assurer un
travail partenariat et coordonné de
l'ensemble des services de l'État pour
le ministère de la Ville 2024 donc sera
une année de réforme la géographie
prioritaire sera renouvelé et le zonage
qui n'a pas été mis à jour depuis 10 ans
le sera pas pour la métropole les
travaux ont été mené tout au long de
l'année 2023 nous avons travaillé avec
les élus et les préfets pour définir les
contours des futurs qpv au plus proche
de chaque territoire pour nous assurer
que ce zonage puisse répondre aux
besoins des plus
fragiles ce grand chantier est en cours
de finalisation et le nouveau décret
sera publié avant le 31 décembre 2023
pour une entrée en vigueur au 1er
janvier 2024 ce zonage comme tout zonage
n'est pas exent d'e fait de seuil pour
répondre à cela j'ai souhaité qu'une
partie des crédits du programme 147
puisse de façon circonscrite être
utilisé dans les quartiers qui ne
remplissent pas ou plus tous les
critères mais qui rencontrent des
difficultés similaires pour tenir pour
tenir compte encore une fois des
réalités social des territoires cela
permettra notamment de continuer à
soutenir la dynamique des quartiers
sortants et je pense que sortir d'un
quartier prioritaire c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle mais il faut un
accompagnement très
spécifique concernant l'outre-em les
particularités de ces territoires
ultramarins doivent être prises en
compte c'est dans cet esprit qu'une
mission gouvernementale interinspection
de révision des contrat de ville a été
mise en place ces ces conclusions ont
été rendues et permettent d'aiguiller la
réflexion du gouvernement pour une
meilleure prise en charge des
spécificités de ces territoires le
zonage ultramarin sera mis à jour selon
la même méthodologie partagé entre élu
et préfets durant l'année 2024 pour une
entrée en vigueur au 1er janvier
2025 la réforme de la géographie
prioritaire s'accompagnera par ailleurs
de la conclusion de nouveaux contrat de
ville au 1emier trimestre 2024
initialement prévu pour le 31 décembre
2023 ces quelques mois supplémentaires
accordés pour leur signature permettront
d'intégrer la nouvelle logique que nous
souhaitons leur donner en effet je
voulais mettre fin à l'application de
directive et de priorités nationales
indistinctement sur tout le territoire
désormais l'impulsion viendra des
habitants et des acteurs locaux qui
définiront ensemble et bien évidemment
avec l'État local les priorités et les
actions à mettre en œuvre dans leur
territoire c'est tout le sens de la
circulaire que j'ai signé le 31 août
2023 et qui a notamment permis de
prolonger la phase de concertation avec
les habitants jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'octobre s'agissant des associations
dont je veux ici souligner l'engagement
nécessaire il me semble indispensable de
leur faire confiance à priori tout en
contrôlant les actions effectuées à
postériori il faut également leur donner
de la visibilité 50 % des conventions
devont devront être pluriannuels et les
subventions en fonctionnement pour les
petites associations devront être
facilité ces contrats doivent être
appréhendés comme étant de véritables
projets partenariaux pour les
territoires entre l'État les les
opérateurs privés et associatifs ainsi
que évidemment les collectivités dont
vous êtes les représentants et qui sont
nos interlocuteurs naturels j'ai
d'ailleurs souhaité qu'un volet
investissement soit intégré dans les
contrats de ville lorsqu'il existe des
cofinancement pour avoir une approche
globale ces contrats devront être
également permettre de pardon ces
contrats devront également permettre une
meilleure coordination avec les
différentes contractualisations
existantes notamment avec les contrats
territoriaux d'accueil et d'intégration
mais également avec le déploiement du
plan pauvreté Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur 2024 sera également une année
de transition en matière fiscale
l'ensemble des dispositifs fiscaux de la
politique de la ville ont été prolongé
en première lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale les zones franches urbaines en
202 24 l'abattement de 30 % de la taxe
foncière sur les propriétés bâties la
TFPB pour les bailleurs sociaux jusqu'en
2030 mais également les taux réduits de
TVA pour la construction et la
rénovation des logements dans les
quartiers prioritaires à l'heure où nous
refondons le zonage des quartier
prioritaire je lancerai ainsi dès le
début de l'année 2024 la réflexion pour
engager une réforme de la fiscalité au
bénéfice des quartiers prioritaires pour
une mise en place dans le PLF 2025 l'obj
objectif sera d'avoir des exonérations
simples et lisibles qui permettent de
soutenir l'émergence des activités
économiques dans les quartiers
prioritaire le développement du commerce
de proximité par exemple et le soutien à
l'emploi enfin la dernière réforme que
je souhaite mener en 2024 concerne la
professionnalisation des adultes relais
les événements de juin l'ont montré la
médiation a permis d'éviter
l'embrasement de certains territoires et
favoriser le retour au calme la présence
humaine est ainsi primordiale et il est
indispensable que les personnes qui
jouent ce rôle soient formées à la
médiation aujourd'hui on demande à des
personnes qui ne sont pas dans des
situations stable de s'occuper d'autres
personnes qui ont encore plus de
problèmes il faut sortir de ces emplois
il faut sortir ces emplois d'une forme
de
précarité je veux réinventer une
présence humaine symbole de chaleur
humaine mais aussi d'autorité cette
réforme sera en concertation avec
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés et et
avec une mise en œuvre progressive pour
permettre la montée en comp
lorsque cela est nécessaire et possible
comme vous le voyez beaucoup de réformes
sont actuellement en cours et elle pent
en elle la même philosophie
simplification confiance concertation et
travail partenarial je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre pour
ses propos et je cède sans plus tarder
la parole à notre rapporteur pour avis
Vivian
Artigalas merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre ma première question
merci d'abord de votre présence merci
d'être ici ma première question portera
sur les moyens du
npnru comme vous le savez la subvention
de l'enrue est attribué une fois pour
toutes sans actualisation or avec
l'inflation les coûts croissants de
construction plusieurs villes concernées
qui sont des communes pauvres où des
bailleurs n'ont pas les moyens
d'apporter le complément et vont
peut-être devoir renoncer à leur projet
de rénovation uber urbaine quelle
solution proposez-vous je voudrais
ensuite savoir comment va être assuré le
suivi du CIV la proposition de notre
rapport que Dominique a déjà évoqué euh
c'était de signer de nouvelles
conventions interministérielle
d'objectif pour garantir l'arrivée du
droit commun dans les quartiers elle a
été reprise cette proposition mais moi
je voudrais en connaître le calendrier
au-delà le CIV va-t-il avoir des suites
législatives et budgétaires à court
terme est-ce que ce CIV induit des
amendements du Gouvernement dans le PLF
à moyen terme alors que plusieurs des
annonces doivent se décliner sur les
trois ou quatre prochaines années une
loi de programmation pour la ville
est-elle envisagée comme nous le
proposions dans notre rapport enfin dans
quelle mesure votre ministère est-il
impliqué dans les projets de loi sur
l'habitat indigné et les copropriétés
dégradé qui concerne au premiers chefs
les quartiers prioritaires et sur la
décentralisation de la politique de la
du logement alors que la loi de 2014
mériterait d'être toiletté je voudrais
prendre l'exemple de la prise en charge
des poches de pauvreté souvent dans les
centres villees anciens qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui reconnus nous le demandions
dans notre rapport il me semble que cela
été confirmé par l'analyse des émeutes
de l'été qui n'ont pas eu lieu que dans
les quartiers politiques de la ville je
vous remercie voilà je vous propose de
répondre à notre rapporteur madame la
ministre
euh madame la rapporteur donc sur les
crédits en rue évidemment que ça a été
pris en compte puisque euh au dernier
PLF une une augmentation du budget qui
va être dédié à l'enrue pour pour
commencer à compenser on le sait le coût
des travaux on connaît l'inflation je
connais ça comme vous euh ce qui est sûr
c'est que est-ce que 50 millions ce sera
suffisant on je vais suivre ça de très
près puisque cet argent va être affecté
à à l'enrue je j'en discuta avec mon
collègue vergrit encore hier et ce qui
est sûr aussi c'est que la trésorerie de
l'enrue pour pour l'instant et et bien
ce que je enfin et bien 839 millions
d'euros ce que je crois surtout c'est
que l'État s'est engagé euh à garantir
enfin moi je je vois ça comme ça et
c'est comme ça en fait que le président
même de la République l'avait l'avait
dit et il a eu raison il n'y aura pas de
défaut de paiement les choses seront
assurées et toutes les communes qui
rencontreront une difficulté je le dis
ici devant vous vous êtes la
représentation nationale aucune commune
ne sera abandonnée on est enfin je on
est en France on est la 6e puissance
mondiale j'ose imaginer que sur des
programmes moi souvent je suis alertée
alors pas sur les les moyens où par
exemple allez on va prendre Marseille
parce que c'est c'est là où on a affecté
650 millions d'euros pour l'enrue
euh à peine 1 million d'euros dépensé
mais c'est un autre débat euh la réalité
c'est que c'est pas tellement là où je
vais avoir des sujets sur les coûts
d'inflation c'est plutôt sur les petites
communes moi les euh ville et banlieu
enfin toutes les associations d'élus
m'alerte plutôt sur les petites communes
exactement donc c'est plutôt sur des
montants c'est 150000 € 200000 € ça peut
aller jusqu'à 1 million d'euros j'ose
espérer j'ose espérer qu'on sera à la
hauteur et on le sera donc si ça peut
vous rassurer en tout cas ça c'est un
engagement que j'ai pris parce que
effectivement on peut pas demander à une
petite commune la même chose qu'à une
commune qui a d'autres ressources
d'autres moyens de financement donc ça
c'est pour euh votre vous rassurer sur
l'en rue après sur euh la le suivi du
CIV je rappelle juste quelques mesures
importantes
euh le président les avait déjà annoncé
à Marseille lors de sa venue sur euh
c'était juste avant les émeutes hein si
vous vous rappelez bien c'était fin juin
l'ouverture des collèges 8h 18h on est à
peu près euh de mémoire à 90 collèges
volontaires parce qu'on peut pas
l'imposer comme ça on fait un travail
avec les départements l'éducation
nationale évidemment euh et je parlais
tout à l'heure de la mobilisation du
droit commun c'est laj vaste sujet mais
moi ce que je crois et je je le dis
encore une fois devant vous devant la
représentation nationale j'espère qu'un
jour il n'y aura plus de Bob 147 moi la
réalité c'est que j'espère qu'un jour
nos quartiers prioritaires seront juste
dans le droit commun c'est-à-dire que le
droit commun suffira à organiser non
mais c'est si on veut un idéal on doit
toujours tendre non mais ça a toujours
été l'objectif mais mais je crois qu'on
l'a probablement oublié ces dernières
décennies je pense que les et si on veut
tendre à cet idéal si on doit tendre
vers ça on doit pouvoir l'évaluer nous
sommes pour l'instant et je je vous le
dis de manière très très sincère on
n'est pas capable pour l'instant
d'évaluer
exactement la la mobilisation du droit
commun dans nos quartiers prioritaires
et c'est pour ça que je pense que la
représentation nationale j'étais député
euh pendant un an et je pense que ça
peut être le rôle de l'Assemblée
nationale par exemple d'évaluer chaque
année
la mobilisation du droit commun sur nos
quartiers prioritaires donc euh les
mesures CIV donc je vous parlais du 8h
18h on on peut parler aussi de
l'ouverture de classe à partir de 2 ans
donc l'accueil des enfants à partir de 2
ans et évidemment les élus m'ont
interpellé nous ont interpellé en me
disant et en nous disant qui va
payer évidemment que on ne laissera pas
seul euh la charge euh aux communes mais
même pas c'est c'est même pas ça c'est
que le l'éducation nationale a tout son
rôle à jouer quand il s'agit de
l'ouverture des collèges de 8h à 18h le
l'accueil des enfants à partir de 2 dans
les quartiers prioritaires parce que
c'est une remontée ça des habitants qui
disent les moyens de garde sont trop
limités dans les quartiers prioritaires
et il est plus simple pour les parents
pour plein de raisons de laisser ses
enfants à l'école qu'à la crèche donc je
pense que c'est une excellente mesure
mais encore une fois on on ne peut la
généraliser que sur la base du
volontariat pour démarrer en on tempend
vers 2024 donc la rentrée 2024 à leure
généralisation les cités éducatives euh
madame la Présidente c'est un dispositif
qui fonctionne très bien
208 cités éducatives 28 millions d'euros
mobilisés donc on a récupéré ces crédits
sur ce qui était prévu pour les
bataillons de la prévention euh et
j'espère une généralisation enfin
j'espère on va monter en charge jus
jusqu'en 2027 et pareil on ne peut pas
imposer une cité éducative vous voyez
bien comment ça donc on a des communes
qui sont candidates on a des des élus
qui sont tout de suite venus nous voir
donc généraliser à la fin du donc 2027
les cités éducatives sera possible parce
que chaque année à chaque PLF et c'est
prévu il y aura des crédits affectés
dédiés spécifiquement pour les cités
éducatives parce qu'encore une fois
quand on a testé quelque chose et que ça
FA fonctionne il faut le généraliser en
revanche je pense que sur les bataillons
de la prévention il fallait avoir aussi
un constat lucide on a des endroits
reince Marseille ça a marché très bien
Nice et j'ai demandé au préfets et et
aux élus locaux de me remonter les
bataillons de la prévention qui
fonctionnaient et ceux qui ne
fonctionnaient pas je vais vous dire de
manière très pragmatique on les a arrêté
et on réfléchi à d'autres dispositifs
euh on parle par exemple des forces
d'action républicaines
euh ouais c'est c'est alors euh juste
pour vous faire si vous me permettez
madame la Présidente en 30 secondes euh
c'est un dispositif voulu par le
Président de la République il l'avait
annoncé à Marseille c'est de pouvoir
permettre dans les quartiers
prioritaires d'avoir au même endroit
qu'il n'y ait plus de rupture dans euh
le service public parce que à territoire
exceptionnel politique exceptionnel
avoir des magistrats la police avoir les
travailleurs sociaux avoir euh les
associations avoir les habitants et que
lorsqu'un problème est signalé on puisse
y répondre rapidement parce que ce qui
ce qui a ce que nous avons vu pendant
les émeutes notamment c'est que les
territoires parmi les plus touchés ce
sont eux où justement il y avait une
rupture sur le service publici et on
avait plus cette capacité en réalité de
percevoir le terrain donc on a décidé de
Valance maugge la trème ville ben
Besançon Besançon mug et Valence pour
une une expérimentation moi je crois
beaucoup à l'ex expérientation parce que
ça permet quand même de se questionner
moi je ne crois pas que qui que ce soit
que ce soit le gouvernement les
parlementaires les élus locaux personne
n'a de solution magique en revanche je
pense qu'on on doit se s'autoriser à
expérimenter à garder ce qui fonctionne
et à arrêter ce qui ne fonctionne pas et
ça ce qui n'empêche pas en réalité euh
de de progresser quand je dis les les
bataillons de la prévention vous l'avez
vu chez vousanis ça a fonctionné mais là
où ça a fonctionné ça a vraiment aidé
les gens dans leur vie quotidienne je
l'avais dit dès que j'ai été nommé pour
moi les politiques de la ville ne sont
pas une politique figée c'est une
politique du vivant c'est la politique
c'est la seule même politique du
quotidien c'est le seul endroit où vous
pouvez parler aux gens tous les jours de
tout de transition écologique de santé
d'éducation et et encore une fois pour
finir de vous répondre madame la
Présidente sur les cités éducatives
c'est aussi l'endroit où les parents
reviennent à l'école où le P moi j'ai
j'ai fait du soutien scolaire merci
d'avoir rappelé rapidement mon parcours
j'ai moi j'avais démarré dans mon
quartier alors juste pour le situer pour
ceux qui le connaissent pas à Marseille
euh dans le 3è arrondissement c'était
c'est l'une des zones les plus pauvres
d'Europe mais qui n'était pas à l'époque
de mes parents ça s'est paupérisé ces 30
dernières années euh j'ai fait du
soutien scolaire mais on faisait quoi je
faisais quoi quand j'étais au lycée
j'allais chercher les gamins à l'école
je les on faisait ben le goûter on
faisait l'école c'estàd on faisait les
devoir et je l'ai ramené chez eux moi je
crois beaucoup beaucoup au fait de
pouvoir soulager les parents sur cet
aspect- là de travailler sur le
périscolaire mais je dis aussi nos
enfants ne peuvent pas aller enfin on ne
peut pas dire toute la journée ils sont
à l'école ils font les devoirs après
l'école 2h mais il faut aussi qu'il
puissent se divertir donc sur le dégel
par vous m'avez pas posé la question
mais je vous le dis parce que j'y pense
euh j'ai décidé d'affecter 4 million
d'euros aux vacances d'hiver donc sur le
modèle de Quartier d'été faire les
quartiers d'hiver pour les vacances de
Noël et pour les vacances de février
parce que je considère que dans les
quartiers prioritaires aussi pour les
vacances de Noël et les vacances de
février nos enfants ont le droit d'avoir
des activités de qualité et juste une
petite
digression rapide euh sur les les Jeux
olympiques mais deux portefeuilles
citoyenneté et ville euh la ministre des
sport nous a affecté à peu près 20000
places pour assister aux compétitions et
j'ai décidé sur le bob 140 donc de
prendre 3 million d'euros pour pouvoir
transporter nos enfants donc les loger
les nourrir euh et les emmener sur les
site de Jo de manière correcte
c'estàdire il faut de l'argent pour
pouvoir les transporter on sait très
bien que les les transports vont prendre
voilà tout tout va être multiplié par
deux et j'ai considéré que chaque enfant
de chaque territoire qui était éloigné
de des zones on va dire de compétition
devait avoir accès aussi et participer à
ce grand événement que sont nos jeux
olympiques et voilà donc dites-moi si
j'ai oublié quelque chose je pourrais
toujours reprendre par rapport à la
question que vous a posé vienne sur une
loi de programmation de la politique de
la
ville alors en tout cas c'est en
discussion j'en discutais hier justement
avec mon collègue vergrit le sujet sur
la table le sujet est sur la table et je
pense que ni lui ni moi ne sommes
capables de dire là tout de suite c'est
exactement comme ça qu'on va le faire et
puis moi je crois beaucoup travail du
Parlement ENF moi je compte sur mes
anciens collègues à l'Assemblée
nationale pour s du sujet et et vous
évidemment au Sénat pour nous proposer
il faut qu'on on le fasse ensemble moi
je peux pas imaginer qu'on décide là
maintenant en 1h3 de faire ou pas une
loi de programmation les mesures sur le
CIV ont été annoncé beaucoup de mesures
on je je parlais dans mon introduction
de la transition
écologique les 15 % affectés et je vous
le dis pareil avec la plus grande
sincérité en ayant réuni les préfets et
les acteurs associat
j'ai demandé et ça c'est une demande
solennelle que je leur ai faite de dire
vous savez on peut parler de transition
écologique dans nos quartiers
prioritaires mais si on arrêtait aussi
de faire ramasser les déchets aux
enfants le dimanche c'est bien parce que
je pense qu'il y a d'autres choses à
faire dans des quartiers prioritaires
qui manquent d'illot de fraîcheur où on
manque justement de lieux partagés où
les gens peuvent aller que ce soit
cultiver leur potager ou faire d'autres
activités avec leurs enfants donc des
activités familiales je pense que le
dimanche les enfants des quartiers
prioritaires ont d'autres activités un
peu plus intéressantes à faire que
ramasser des déchets qui n'ont pas
produit merci donc on va ouvrir le jeu
des questions je vous propose madame la
ministre de répondre au fur à mesure que
nos collègues vont vous poser des
questions donc on commence avec Franck
Montauger merci madame la Présidente
merci Madame La la la ministre je
voudrais euh en préambule remercier les
ensemble des acteurs qui concourent au
développement de la politique de la
ville en France je je le dis à partir
d'une d'une expérience de terrain
relative à la ville d'che puisque je
suis sénateur du du du Gers où où les
choses se passent plutôt bien donc voilà
il faut il faut savoir le reconnaître et
même si même si beaucoup reste à faire
voilà on en a tous conscience je
voudrais vous interroger madame la
ministre sur un point important des
missions qui vous sont dévolues celui
relatif à la
citoyenneté auquel je je je lis la
question de la laïcité vous avez parlé
d'indicateur tout à
l'heure je voudrais savoir si cet aspect
là du comportement qui nous concerne
tous et pas que les habitants des
quartiers de la politique de la ville en
tant que
citoyen comment comment il est apprécié
en réalité bon on voit on voit se
développer hélas des phénomènes de de de
Sécession euh de sécessions
républicaines euh voilà je je je ne je
n'illustre pas on a tous des événements
récents tragique en tête je voudrais
savoir voilà quel est votre plan
d'action en la matière
euh voilà comment l'effectivité du fait
laïque de la laïcité est-il apprécié par
votre
ministère sur quoi le cas échéant repose
votre plan d'action de renforcement de
la laïcité des des comportements voilà
euh conformes conformes à à à à à ce
principe et je voudrais savoir si dans
le le budget 2024 ce ce type d'action
donne lieu à une budgétisation et et et
à et à quelle hauteur et sur quel réseau
d'acteurs euh vous vous appuyez et et
dernier point en de dernier point autre
point
euh quel est votre plan de de de de
convergence du droit dérogatoire de la
politique de la ville actuelle vers le
droit commun que vous avez évoqué voilà
comment vous envisagez la convergence
des dispositifs jusqu'à ce que le droit
commun concerne évidemment en totalité
voilà et dernier point sur l'éducation
j'arrête après madame la Présidente sur
l'éducation vous vous avez vous avez
abordé le sujet en fin de
propos alors ça va peut-être choquer
j'espère que non
euh moi je trouve et et ça ne vaut
certainement pas que pour les les
quartiers politique de la ville la
question de l'éducation des parents ou
se
pose
voilà non pas évidemment pour les
stigmatiser mais pour les aider dans
leur vie et et dans leur dans leur
rapport notamment aux enfants à l'acte à
l'acte à l' à l'acte éducatif qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'il est qu'est-ce qui est
prévu V en la matière quel est votre
plan d'action en la matière parce que
moi je ne vois rien à cet égard si ce
n'est des choses qui reposent et c'est
déjà pas mal et il faut les en remercier
sur les acteurs associatifs voilà mais
comment le ministère comment le
gouvernement sur un sujet comme ça
envisage de développer des actions
spécifiques à l'instar des cités
éducatives que vous avez venez d'évoquer
concernant les enfants euxmêm merci
madame la ministre monsieur le sénateur
merci mer pour votre question alors h il
me semble que vous avez récupéré un
préfet délégué Laurent carrier qui était
à Marseille c'est c'est le préfet oui
oui oui non mais il était pédec à
Marseille il avait fait un travail
remarquable CIT juste pour souligner que
vous
avez chez vous maintenant depuis
quelques mois quelqu'un qui avait fait
un travail remarquable à Marseille alors
plusieurs
chos plusieurs choses donc je vous
réponds probablement dans le désordre je
je commence par la fin de votre question
et je je reviendrai au début euh sur la
mobilisation du droit commun et comment
faire converger les deux si je prends un
exemple par exemple le Marseille en
grand que le président le grand plan de
sauvetage de Marseille que le président
a voulu il y a 2 ans maintenant c'est le
meilleur exemple de mobilisation du
droit commun pour une ville en
souffrance donc ça veut dire que quand
on sait évaluer les choses on arrive
mieux à y répondre donc c'est pour ça
que j'insiste vraiment sur les v ben
ouais ouais moi mon sujet quand même
c'est je vous le disais je crois
énormément au travail parlementaire j'ai
adoré être député parce que ça nous
permet une grande marge d'AC enfin
vraiment une grande marge dans
l'évaluation dans le questionnement dans
le fait de pouvoir travailler avec tous
les acteurs locaux et de se questionner
sur nos politiques donc je pense que
avant de de se poser la question de la
convergence moi je pose la question de
l'évaluation et le Sénat est vraiment
que ce soit l'Assemblée nationale ou le
Sénat nous devons enfin vous devez
maintenant travailler ensemble à cette
évaluation et je vais le proposer je le
porte de manière très forte auprès de la
première ministre auprès du ministre
Gérard Lanin auprès du président de la
République parce que je pense que c'est
le préalable à tout le reste parce que
sinon on se retrouvera encore dans une
commission l'année prochaine et je vous
dirai encore bah alors le Do non moi je
veux savoir exactement ENF je veux
savoir je voudrais j'espère que nous
serons capables chaque année de
l'évaluer pour répondre à chaque fois
plus précisément et mieux aux demandes
et aux besoins des habitants de ces
quartiers prioritaire après sur la
citoyenneté vous avez des indicateurs
madame la ministre on a alors je vais
vous dire
euh dans une une grande ville comme
Marseille je suis capable de le faire
mais encore une fois les préfets savent
faire ça il savent nous donner les moi
je les demande je demande sur la vidéo
protection par exemple j'ai demandé la
semaine dernière ou la semaine d'avant
au préfet de me remonter une info simple
mobilisation du droit commun sur la
vidéo protection combien sont affectés
euh à telle ville combien dépenser
combien déployer et si c'est pas fait
pourquoi ce n'est pas fait donc je suis
on est capable de le faire mais vous
imaginez que euh on ne peut pas tout le
temps aller sonner si vous me permettez
l'expression les préfets moi je crois
que on est capable en tant enfin je
pense que les parlementaires encore une
fois sont capables de le faire donc sur
des des choses précises oui je suis
capable de répondre mais la réalité pour
l'instant moi je suis incapable de
répondre à votre question de dire
combien euh enfin que représente le
droit combien dans les quartiers
prioritaires je sais pas vous dire
précisément je peux vous dire les les
budgets qui sont euh des dédié au
ministère évidemment sur la citoyenneté
alors vous avez raison de parler de
laïcité c'est mais on parle de laïcité
on parle de lutte contre la délinquence
on parle de lutte contre la
radicalisation j'ai décidé une mesure
simple c'est sur la base des contrats de
ville nous avons des contrats de ville
qui fonctionnent bien que les préfets
savent parfait ement géré que les élus
locaux euh pareil connaissent c'est un
dispositif euh très connu de sur tous
nos territoires je fais un bilan de tous
les dispositifs qui sont à ma main à la
citoyenneté l'apprentissage du français
de partout où je me déplace de halon en
passant par par newor les maires me
parlent de quoi en me disant moi j'ai
des sujets parce que je j'accueille des
populations primo arrivantes et j'ai un
souci sur l'apprentissage du français
donc je fais un bilan de tous les
dispositifs
au sein du ministère de la Citoyenneté
sur l'intégration sur l'asile sur la
naturalisation sur la lutte contre la
radicalisation sur la prévention de la
délinquence et euh et la laïcité et de
dire est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable
d'imaginer puisque des crédits sont
dédiés aussi à ces à ces dispositifs de
les accoller au contrat de ville et
évidemment pour les quartiers qui ne
sont pas prioritaires on décidera d'un
autre dispositif mais là on parle des
quartiers prioritaires et de les mettre
dans un même socle et que ce soit encore
une fois chez le préfet parce que le
préfet reste quand même le représentant
de l'État si je puis dire le plus fiable
celui qu'on va tout le temps sonner
quand on a besoin de quelque chose et je
pense que ça peut répondre à à toutes
les problématiques je veux dire dès
qu'on aura une question à poser ou un
besoin de financement et je réiniste sur
la possibilité de financer vous me
permettez juste d'y revenir les petites
associations et de faire a priori j'ai
vu quelque chose de très simple moi je
suis quelqu'un de normal de pragmatique
enfin je sais
et qui connaît le mieux les habitants y
a deux personnes il y a l'élu il y a le
maire et les associations qui sont au
bas des immeubles et je pense que de
continuer à leur demander de faire des
choses infaisables c'est-à-dire
donnez-moi votre plan pour 3 ans on ne
les finance pas donc elles peuvent pas
avoir de visibilité les appels à projet
les appels à projet pour répondre à un
appel à projet SI si vous n'avez pas
fait Lena sence po x en même temps hein
parce que il faut être très très
intelligent pour les les faire on peut
pas y arriver donc moi j'ai demandé une
simplification pour les petites
associations ça représente 50
% des des budgets crédit de ville crédit
de contrat de ville pardon pour qu'on
puisse faire enfin confiance à nos
acteurs locaux et encore une fois on est
capable d'évaluer à postériori moi je je
ne veux pas avoir de préjugés et je
préfère qu'on se plante parce que il
aura les une association sur 1000 qui
fera pas bien le travail mais les 999
elles feront bien le travail et c'est
pareil pour les appels à projet je
penser que parce qu'on a mis des appels
à projet très complexes très compliqué
il y aura pas de défaillance c'est pas
vrai non plus mais dans en règle
générale et quand je regarde de manière
très froide les chiffres les
associations font le job un job
remarquable et je reviens sur votre
question
euh sur quels sont les moyens je vous
parlais des adultes relais
les la médiation pour moi est tu est un
vrai métier une vocation et comment
est-ce qu'on peut demander à des gens
qui sont dans des difficultés extrêmes
vous connaissez les les critères pour
être un adulte relé comment voulez-vous
que quelqu'un qui ne va pas bien a aider
quelqu'un qui va pas bien c'est pas
possible donc je propose et je l'ai
demandé une refonte totale ça passera
peut-être même pas par la loi une refond
total du statut ça représente 88 18
million d'euros le le budget adulte rela
donc je considère qu'avec à peu près 100
million d'euros 6500 adultes relais je
préfère qu'il y en ait moins qu'il soit
mieux formé et qu'il soit mieux payé
parce que moi je me retrouve aussi dans
des cas où les élus locaux me disent je
ou les associations vous disent je ne
veux pas de cet adulte relais parce
qu'en fait il est pas formé il
correspond pas il peut pas faire le
travail je pense que si on démarre pas
par ça et dans la formation des adultes
relais je veux une formation
laïcité lutte contre la radicalisation
et prévention de la délinquence parce
que c'est Mo aussi la prévention qui a
trop largement disparu de notre langage
commun et vraiment je pense que la
formation des adultes relé probablement
le point d'entrée en mettant pas
uniquement la médiation sociale quand je
parlais d'autorité évidemment en étant
rattaché au ministère de l'Intérieur et
vous le savez mieux que moi vous êtes un
élu local la sécurité le sujet même le
sujet numéro 1 donc je pense que mieux
les former à toutes les problématiques
qu'ils vont rencontrer sur le terrain
mieux les payer les faire monter en
compétence c'est-à-dire probablement
leur donner des qualifications qui quiiv
vaudrait par exemple un bac plus 2
pourquoi pas on est capable de le faire
donc je préfère en avoir 5000 très bien
formé hyper efficac sur le terrain que
6005 où je sais que ça fonctionne pas
parce que je l'ai je l'ai constaté à
titre personnel sur le terrain
euh des gens qui vont pas bien ne
peuvent pas c'est ça tombe sous le sens
ne peuvent pas s'occuper de d'autres
personnes qui ont encore plus de
difficultés merci exclusivement parler
toi attends Fran on a beaucoup de
questions j'ai peur qu'on n'arrive pas à
tenir le timing les parents les parents
vous me laissez une phrase sur les voilà
une les parents la parentalité et c'est
eu euh la la députée que j'étais qui
l'avait dit et je le dis maintenant en
tant que ministre j'ai toujours
considéré que les par donc on était
responsable de ce qu'on fabriquait
sauf en cas de grandes difficultés
social santé mentale enfin à part quand
il y a vraiment un sujet donc moi je
parle de responsabilisation je parle
d'éducation à la parentalité c'est
compliqué d'être parent on n'est pas
parent c'est c'est probablement le job
le plus difficile de la terre et dans
les cités éducatifes tout à l'heure
voyez je répondais je disais oui les
cités éducatives sont un point d'entrée
pour les parents dans leur implication
dans l'éducation dans l'instruction de
leurs enfants et que si on on ne va pas
on ne tend pas vers ça de manière très
forte on pourra mettre tous les moyens
qu'on veut il y a deux bases l'éducation
c'est comme ça qu'on se construit
l'éducation par ses parents et l'école
et après chacun fait ses choix parce que
l'être humain l'être humain étant né
libre nous sommes tous nés libres et
égau devant la loi chacun fait ses choix
mais je pense que si on a à la base
quelque chose d'équitable chacun fait
ses choix mais la base doit être
respectée l'éducation et l'éducation des
parents et l'éducation nationale merci
merci je rappelle à nos collègues qu'on
doit terminer absolument à 10h30 on va
essayer de prendre des questions deux
par deux et je vous demande vraiment
d'être court dans vos questions donc on
va prendre Bernard bu et Antoinette
Gul merci présidente madame la ministre
sénateur de la Drome j'apprécie
l'arrivée de la force d'action
républicaine à Valence vous l'avez cité
tout à l'heure le but avec ce dispositif
est de pouvoir expérimenter et que les
habitants deviennent acteurs de leur
quartier il va falloir que ville état
département et agglomération travaillent
vraiment ensemble sur nos quartiers
sensibles ma question portera sur la
généralisation des cités éducatives vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure en
répondant à ma collègue Viviane
Artigalas pour que tous les quartiers
prioritaires puissent bénéficier de
cette approche il est impératif de
labelliser 650 nouveaux territoires au
cours des quatre prochaines années cela
nécessite un engagement considérable et
la mise en place d'une stratégie
spécifique pour garantir que d'ici 2030
aucun quartier prioritaire ne soit
laissé sans le soutien du cité éducative
pourriez-vous nous donner plus amples
détails sur le plan d'action précis que
vous envisagez pour atteindre cet
objectif et sur les moyens que vous
prévoyez de mobiliser afin de financer
Antoinette Gul
oui madame la Présidente bonjour madame
la ministre chers collègues euh vous
nous avez parlé de Marseille je vous en
remercie moi je vais vous parler de
Paris puisque je suis sénatrice de Paris
et qu'à Paris aussi nous avons des
quartiers populaires dont qui ont
grandement besoin de financement
or il se trouve que la politique de la
ville telle qu'elle est en train d'être
redéfinie va amener à pour Paris une
baisse d'environ 20 % du budget consacré
à la politique de la ville donc moi
j'entends que vous nous expliquiez qu'il
y a énormément de choses à faire
beaucoup d'efforts et cetera mais faire
tout ceci avec une baisse de budget vous
admettrez que c'est quand même assez
contradictoire nous avons besoin de
moyens pour une politique de la ville
ambitieuse à Paris parce que et je tiens
à dire quand même que toutes les
demandes que nous avons fait et not et
notamment l'augmentation des dotations
en rue ont tout été refusé à Paris nous
avons dans les quartier politique de la
ville une jeunesse en grande précarité
nous avons également une situation
environnementale souvent difficile et se
cumule dans ces quartiers non seulement
la précarité mais aussi les pollutions
le bruit et cetera il y a donc un cumule
j'allais dire des inégalités à la fois
sociale et environnementale comme c'est
très souvent le cas dans nos villes nous
avons donc besoin d'une transition
écologique
pour les quartiers et donc à inscrire
dans la politique de la ville dont j'ai
je vous ai peu entendu parler nous avons
bien sûr besoin de réhabilitation un
besoin de renforcement des politiques de
l'emploi et donc moi je m'interroge
parce que avec une baisse de budget nous
ne sommes nous ne serons donc pas en
mesure pour une grande ville comme Paris
qui est tout aussi importante que la
ville de Marseille ou que d'autres
villes en matière de politique de la
ville et de quartier non non mais je le
dis parce que quelquefois on met la
focale sur certaines sur C ville mais
tout ont besoin d'avoir un appui de
l'État pour ce qui concerne les
quartiers prioritaires et donc c'est le
sujet je crois madame la ministre déjà
non ah oui pardon ok je fais pas alors
je réponds en premier à madame la
sénatrice paris est une ville riche
marseille est une ville pauvre un
Marseillais sur deux ne paye pas l'impôt
sur le revenu non pas parce qu'il triche
c'est parce qu'il a pas les moyens donc
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose sur Non Non mais plan de non non
mais non mais vous pouvez pas non mais
vous pouvez pas me me dire que on en
fait que non mais je peux pas vous
laisser dire ça non plus
euh Marseille a eu besoin d'un d'un plan
de sauvetage c'est pas moi qui l'ai
décidé c'est le président de la
République juste je vous réponds Marc
Guillaume Le le
préfet votre préfet euh est venu me voir
en me disant j'ai deux quartiers très
compliqués dans le 15e arrondissement
que j'ai fait rentrer en quartier
prioritaire de la ville il y a pas plus
tard que moi je n'ai jamais dit que
Paris n'avait pas besoin au contraire
les poches de pauvreté à Marseille comme
à Marseille mais à Paris euh sont
gravissimes et je n'ai jamais dit vous
n'aurez jamais entendu de ma bouche dire
on fait uniquement pour Marseille on
fait rien pour Paris c'est pas ça qui
est
ex la réalité c'est que vous parlez de
baisse de budget moi je vous parle de du
doublement par exemple sur le fond vert
15 % vous parliez de transition
écologique et c'est très intéressant 15
% du au PLF 2023 d'accord puisque le
fond vert vous le savez c'est 7
milliards et sur cette année c'est 2
milliards,5 donc 15 % fléché sur nos
quartiers prioritaires j'attends de nos
élus bien sûr de nos préfets j'attends
de tous ceux qui ont envie de s'emparer
de ce sujet euh de s'en emparer puisque
les crédits sont là ils sont ils sont au
PLF ils sont affectés et que vous je ne
sais pas si vous étiez arrivé quand je
l'ai dit
euh je pense qu'on a beaucoup de choses
à faire sur la transition écologique
autre que faire ramasser les déchets aux
enfants le weekend donc ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir un peu aussi se creuser
la tête pour proposer des choses pour
changer la vie des gens dans leur
quotidien moi je préfère qu'on
investisse très largement dans l'habitat
dans la l'alimentation l'alimentation
dont on on parle finalement très peu
plutôt que de dire sur la transition
écologique on va les éduquer à ramasser
les déchets je dis pas que c'est vous
non mais je j'avais dit j'avais dit dès
que j'ai été nommé plus non non pas vous
pas vous non non je je non pas non je je
vous réponds
sur
absolument non absolument mais donc je
je demande au maire de réfléchir un peu
différemment et la transition écologique
étant pour moi je l'avais dit dès que
j'ai été nommé plus de bleu plus de vert
et plus de vert c'était ça aussi donc
non il n'y a pas de baisse parce que je
vous rappelle que on augmente le les les
budgets et les
crédits du 147 je rappelle juste un
chiffre 2017 397 million d'euros
Bob 147 vous me l'accordez 636 millions
d'euros cette année donc on peut pas
dire que sous le quinquena du président
de la République le prier et maintenant
le 2 il y a eu une baisse il y a eu une
augmentation même un doublement euh ça
c'est la première chose et euh et et de
dire qu'à un moment donné euh on fait
sur notre notre zonage par exemple on
oublie Paris c'est pas vrai la preuve
j'ai j'ai regardé précisément puisque on
m'avait alerté les députés m'avaient
déjà alerté et deux quartiers
prioritaires r donc Paris n'est pas du
tout oublié dans les la politique de la
ville sur les cités éducatives euh à
2027 monsieur le sénateur 214 millions
d'euros seront alloués pour soutenir le
développement des 850 cités éducatives
qui seront qui seront prêtes on va dire
et lancé d'ici 2025 euh 2027 pardon 205
million d'euros pour le donc sur les
crédits du Bob 147 et 9 million d'euros
sur le programme du du P de 230 donc
voilà donc les cités éducatives il y a
une vraie volonté et de vrais moyens de
vrais crédits alloués pour les déployer
à 2000 à 2027 la vraie généralisation
avec les crédits qui sont sctuirisé donc
je vous répète le chiffre de 114
millions d'euros à 2027 merci donc on va
prendre Serge mer ou et Sylvia de Noël
si vous pouvez faire
cours bien madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues je veux
madame la ministre d'abord saluer votre
parcours personnel euh je voudrais
évoquer le problème du logement qui est
un élément essentiel de la politique de
la ville et et vous et évoquer la
demande de la première ministre qui a
adressé une circulaire au préfet leur
demandant de ne plus accorder au dans
les quartiers dans les quartiers
prioritaires de logement au au ménages
relevant du du dallo
euh ce qui qui me paraît utile pour
éviter les ghos et favoriser la mixité
sociale donc l'intention est
probablement bonne mais où allez-vous
les loger ces ces ménage relevant du
dalallot qu'avez-vous prévu à cet effet
et à l'heure où où la construction de
logement sociaux est est cruellement en
panne allez-vous prendre des mesures
pour redynamiser la construction de
logement sociaux dans l'ensemble du pays
euh je voudrais aussi évoquer la loi SRU
comment allez-vous faire appliquer la
loi SRU au moment où les communes sont
confrontées à à la nécessité de
construire des lurgemins sociaux et pris
à Neto par le Zand qui laisse pour
certaines communes pas de terrain
constructible disponible moi j'ai le cas
d'une commune la commune de prigorieux
qui pe des pénalités dont le maire est
est très actif en matière de de
construction de logements sociaux mais
qui se heurte à cette difficulté le zan
lui interdit ENF il y a pas de
disponibilité sur le zan voilà et puis
je voudrais vous dire je regrette aussi
en matière de construction de logement
l'oubli des des zones rurales alors je
sais que vous êtes ce sont des sujets
qu'on a évoqué d'accord directement de
son ministère plus que de Madame la
Ministre même s'il y a voà je m' arrêté
là merci alors je crois que syvi laiss
tomber sa question donc c'est Fabi
merci Madame la président bonjour madame
la ministre je sais pas par où commencer
je vous avoue bon je vais commencer par
un point d'accord avec vous euh vous
vous vous
euh attendez j'ai une minute donc si si
on me coupe pendant 20 secondes c'est
pas bien non j'ai un point d'accord avec
vous je suis sénateur la saintanie moi
aussi j'ai grandi dans un quartier
populaire à Bordeaux tout ça euh je
pense que les quartiers prioritaires on
a appelé ça on a appelé ça les zones
sensibles avant bon bref ça a eu
plusieurs noms doivent rentrer dans les
politiques publiques euh normal et c'est
vrai que quand on vient d'un quartier
populaire on est élu d'un d'un
territoire comme la sainsie Marseille ou
d'autres moi jeppose pas d'ailleurs
territoire les quartiers populaires les
zones rurales parce que où les
territoires ultramarins on vit on vit
les mêmes problèmes de façon différente
mais le recul des services publics il
est partout et donc moi je moi je viens
d'un quartier populaire je su je suis un
gamin de ça mais je nppose pas parce que
je vois ici plein de collègues on a pas
la même réalité mais on a les mêmes
difficultés donc on a besoin de rentrer
dans les politiques publiques et moi
j'en ai marre à chaque fois je viens de
la sain sa on a eu Édouard Philippe qui
est venu qui a reconnu qu'on était
discriminé un grand plan bon très bien
on va rattraper une fois qu'on aura
rattrapé on aura encore pris 20 ans de
retard c'est ça le problème et je pense
qu'on a on besoin d'une vision globale
il y a la rénovation urbaine mais il y a
tout le reste la République elle
s'incarne par des hommes et par des
femmes et par des services public et par
le travail et par plein de choses moi je
vous vous voyez ce matin là j'ai pris le
RB comme plein de gens bon ça va j'ai
pas de patron voyez on paye le même prix
du Pass Navigo mais on a pas le même et
c'est c'est pas contre les Parisiens moi
je je m'oppose pas mais on paye le même
prix que les Parisiens et on n' pas le
même service nous il est dégradé chaque
jour les gens ils galèrent en sints pour
aller bosser et et dans tout ça l'accès
à la justice l'accès à la sécurité
l'accès à l'éducation c'est tout ça
qu'il faut revoir et donc c'est une
politique globale globalement et on a
besoin d'une vision et c'est pas contre
vous que je dis ça non non mais je dis
ça parce qu'il y a non mais attendez je
vais au bout et après on en discute mais
je je pense que depuis un moment on n
pas une vision globale donc c'est pas
que vous d'accord et je mets tout le
monde dedans et dernière chose pour
reprendre la question de Serge meriou
sur sur la loi SRU ici on a du débat on
va pas être d'accord avec madame la
Présidente ou madame primat voyez sur la
loi SRU mais par contre ce que vous avez
dit dans la Gazette j'ai lu que c'était
à l'AMF de faire respecter la loi ça je
pense que tous les trois et avec plein
de collègues on est d'accord pour dire
que c'est pas la MF de régler ce
problème c'est à l'État et au préfet
après on a débat on n pas d'accord nous
on veut encstir plus voilà voilà c'est
c'est pas la MF non voilà je vous je
vous dis ça parce que je je pense que
force c'est à la loi quoi voilà madame
la ministre je dirais même duralexlex
mais alors je je réponds en premier bon
en fait finalement tout ça se rejoint
largement sur la mesure de la première
ministre qui a été
évidemment
débatue au sein du gouvernement moi je
pense je l'ai toujours pensé que de
concentrer euh des populations je l'ai
vu que moi mais on le voit de partout
des populations en grande difficulté
toujours au même endroit toujours dans
les mêmes zones toujours sur les mêmes
élus locaux toujours de la même manière
enfin vous voulez que ça donne quoi
après on s'étonne évidemment que le
résultat va être catastrophique donc une
fois que je vous ai dit ça vous me dites
bah comment on fait moi je crois très
sincèrement vous avez dû le lire dans la
Gazette à l'application stricte de la
loi SRU et quand je parle de l'AMF moi
je peux pas entendre des élus locaux qui
ne respectent pas par exemple la loi SRU
qui sont en dessous sur la sur le
logement social je rappelle quand même
et vous le savez mieux que moi que ceux
qui délivrent encore les permis de
construire jusqu'à preuve du contraire
ce sont bien les maires voilà non mais
bien sûr heureusement sauf que quand la
loi SRU n'est pas respectée qu'on a pas
assez de logement sociaux c'est vers
l'état qu'on se tourne donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on continue à tout se mentir
collectivement et à dire bon alors on
sait pas comment on fait moi je crois je
je il est incable de faire non mais
quand un élu local décide de pas d'être
en dessous et vous me per vous me
pardonnerez madame la sénatrice de Paris
de reparler de Marseille euh quand on a
une ville grande comm Marseille 2è plus
grande ville de France qui est hors la
loi en terme de logement social c'est
pas parce que l'État n'a pas voulu
construire on a on a convenonner 650
millions d'euros sur l'en rue c'est
parce qu'on n pas eu les permis de
construire ben une fois que je vous ai
dit ça donc moi je pense sincèrement que
ça ne sert à rien de refaire des lois
sur des lois je l'avais dit dès que je
suis arrivé monsieur le sénateur euh je
je ne crois pas du tout à la
multiplication des lois chacun fait moi
je ferai pas de loi moi je j'ai j'ai pas
envie de faire ça moi ce que je voudrais
c'est prendre l'existant il existe
beaucoup de dispositifs et de travailler
évidemment puisqu'on parle de la loi SRU
avec laamf parce que la réalité c'est
que où est-ce qu'on loge les gens là je
reviens à la la question de votre
collègue évidemment que c'est la
première question mais si on part pas
d'un préalable de dire on va arrêter de
concentrer les mêmes difficultés
toujours chez les mêmes c'est c'est de
la justice on appelle ça de la justice
après il faut aussi faire accepter à
beaucoup d'entre nous enfin à beaucoup
d'entre vous euh le fait que oui ce sont
des populations précaires et je vous
rappelle que dans la circulaire de la
première ministre c'était les dalallos
les plus précaires c'est-à-dire les plus
en difficulté parce que c'est évidemment
CEA qu'on doit le mieux encadrer le
mieux soutenir et évidemment accompagner
euh plus fort plus plus fort que le
reste donc moi je crois à la relance
aussi de la construction mais par les
permis de construire c'est tout ENF j'ai
à un moment donné et on on me parlait
duusan monsieur le voilà monsieur le
sénateur évidemment qu'on crée des
dispositifs qui sont vertueux c'est
vertueux de dire on a envie de moins
polluer personne dans cette dans cette
assemblée dira ben non nous on a envie
d'ê de grands pollueurs mais la réalité
de nos territoires moi je crois je crois
à à la granularité nos territoires sont
tellement différents que je suis pour
une territorialisation des choses
c'est-à-dire de dire chez vous c'est
plus compliqué je dis n'importe quoi que
dans l'est ben alors essayons de
travailler avec le préfet je sais plus
qui m'a interpellé sur le préfet
peut-être d'autres collègues euh de
saintsis bien sûr que l'État le préfet
ont une responsabilité mais à la fois
les les élus locaux nous remontrent
qu'ils veulent avoir la main donc moi ce
que je propose mais très simplement
c'est de faire du règlementaire il faut
arrêter de poser ENF je vais vous dire
déjà qu'on réussisse à faire appliquer
toutes les lois qui ont été voté c'est
un enjeu donc essayons peut-être de
prendre tout ce qui existe de passer par
le règlementairire par les circulaires
par les discussions euh plus intenses
avec la MF parce que vous parliez de de
la de cette association mais il y a
d'autres associations d'élus euh je
pense à France urbain voyez je rencontré
la dernière fois la mère de
Nant qui qui dit aussi qui non mais
voilà mais enfit elle est venue me
proposer des choses tout à fait
pragmatiques et euh et qui tombe sous le
sens mais c'est pas parce que je ne suis
pas du même bord que j'ai pas pris j'ai
pris Joan absolument ben je prends quand
c'est des mesures de bon sens je prends
et très sincèrement pour vraiment finir
madame la Présidente sur la loi SRU je
pense pas qu'il faillit en faire une
autre je pense que si déjà on part sur
une une application stricte et honnête
intellectuellement de la loi SRU je
pense qu'on aura déjà une grande partie
gagné le combat madame la ministre je
vous renverrai aussi à un de nos
rapports fait avec Valérie lettard sur
la loi SRU ni un tabou ni un totem et
faciement peut-être déjà regardons les
lois si elles sont appliqué mais aussi
madame la ministre regardons et veillons
à ce que les décrets d'application ne
mettent pas des mois et des mois avant
de sortir et qui laisse un certain
nombre d'élus et d'acteurs dans les plus
grandes difficultés parce que il y a pas
ces décrets d'application qui sont
sortis donc deux questions Mad président
oui Denis boide et Amel gaaker merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
en 2004 en 2024 seraé en vigueur de la
nouvelle cartographie des quartiers
politiques de la ville dans mon
département le département du gare qui
les mêmes problématiques que le
département des Bouches du Ron notamment
avec Marseille avec les quartiers
difficiles politiques de la ville et
tout ce qu'on peut y voir dedans dans
mon département un effort a été fait
particulièrement sur les dossiers Andru
beaucoup de de de bâtiments ont été
démolis et reconstruits par ailleurs
conséquence de la problématique c'est
par des statistiques qui sont les votres
madame et que je respecte bien sûr où
les avez fait ces dernières années un
investissement important de la part de
l'État dans le cadre de la politique de
la ville mais aussi des départements qui
ont contribué à vos côtés et des
collectivités territoriales qui qui ont
contribué on se retrouve aujourd'hui par
une double peine du fait que nous avons
fait un effort pour faire en sorte que
ces quartiers soient plus agréables que
ceux qui pouvaient l'être du fait du
travail des associations sur les
territoires ces quartiers sortiront des
critères politiques de la ville parce
que le nombre d'habitants a diminué et
je pense que là nous sommes devant un
problème alors je sais pas comment vous
comptez le régler mais moi je considère
c'est de la double peine nous avons fait
un travail important et à l'arrivée nous
sommes pas récompensés
merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre bonjour Alors oui la politique
de la ville c'est vous clairement une
politique essentielle pour notre
cohésion nationale c'est important quand
même de de le rappeler euh moi je je
voudrais dire pourquoi je dis ça parce
que ma première réflexion elle porte
quand même sur le budget dans le cadre
du PLF c'est que orors et madame la
Présidente l'a mentionné hors budget en
rue il stagne voir il baisse et ça c'est
dommage donc vous allez peut-être me
donner des chiffres qui vont peut-être
contre car et ça mais la réalité elle
est là je ne reviens pas sur le constat
actuel euh même si je veux quand même
préciser que il se passe parfois aussi
des choses belle dans les quartiers
prioritaires grâce aux habitants grâce
aux élus grâce au tissus associatifs
c'est quand même important mais il y a
aussi une réalité qui est et je vais
mettre le doigt peut-être sur un point
parce que je le vis si ce n'est pas
quotidiennement mais très régulièrement
sur mon territoire dans le P decalais
c'est la grande solitude bien sûr des
habitants mais aussi des élus des
face à des situations de délinquence
face à des situations bien sûr
d'insécurité et je parle là des trafics
de drogu des trafics de stupéfiants qui
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement compliqués
à gérer peut-être un mot là-dessus je
pense serait serait intéressant alors
vous êtes rassurante sur plusieurs
points je vous le dis mais sur un qui
pour ma part est essentiel c'est
l'importance de la présence
humaine le retour bien sûr des services
publics on en a parlé à plusieurs
reprises mais la présence humaine qui
pour ma part est fondamentale pour ce
qui est des services publics vous n'avez
pas parlé de santé
ou peut-être que vous l'avez fait je
suis passée à côté mais je pense que
c'est important puis deuxième petite
question très courte la participation
citoyenne qui pour ma part est
extrêmement importante alors plusieurs
réflexion plusieurs actions ont été
mises en place notamment la fameuse
commission meschemache vous n'êtes pas
revenu dessus euh est-ce qu'il y a eu un
recadrage lorsque vous êtes arrivé de
cette des actions mises en place puis
qu' aujourd'hui le tour continue hein
elle est passée sur mon territoire
des conseils citoyens qui fonctionnent
ou parfois qui ne fonctionnent
pas donc qu'en est-il parce que c'est un
point important merci Madame la Ministre
merci
beaucoup je suis désolé je commence par
la fin je finis avec vous monsieur le
sénateur sur la commission mchem j'en
attends le rapport j' attends le rapport
donc les concertations se finissaient
fin octobre donc j'attends le rapport
avec impatience et je l'ai je l'ai dit
parce qu'il est temps maintenant
de de passer à l'action
sur la concertation citoyenne et sur la
participation citoyenne moi je pense que
sur les crédits politiques de la ville
on doit la financer on doit inciter on
doit pouvoir inciter les citoyens à
participer donc avoir des outils pour
pouvoir ben donner leur avis chercher à
à améliorer s'impliquer s'impliquer moi
j'ai toujours été impliqué donc je pense
que je ne suis pas vous tous ceux qui
viennent de là ne sont pas des
exceptions euh donc voyez je pense qu'
on doit soutenir c'est pas une idée on
doit soutenir cette action c'est très
important que les gens soient acteurs
moi je déteste j'ai horreur de ça qu'on
décide à la place des gens ce qu'ils
doivent faire où ils doivent manger ce
qu'ils doivent où ils doivent dormir
comment enfin quand je disais nous
sommes des êtres libr et égau une fois
que nous avons la même base chacun fait
ses choix mais après chacun ses choix
par contre sur la santé la santé c'est
l'un de l'un des sujets les les plus
prignants parce que évidemment quand on
a des difficultés on parle de santé mais
de santé mentale aussi H qui reste selon
moi ENF qui reste qui est le parent
pauvre des santé publi mais pas dû à ce
gouvernement évidemment c'est c'est une
politique de 40 ans je ve dire c'est
c'est le manque de formation on sait
que que dans les facs de médecine on n
pas encouragé non plus le fait que on
puisse créer des vocations pour devenir
psychiatre ou psychologue enfit on on
repart 40 ans en arrière et j'en ai 47
donc je pense que beaucoup reste à faire
mais en terme de mobilisation sur la
santé juste vous dire que les maisons de
santé en tout cas tous les élus locaux
qui viennent nous proposer qui viennent
me proposer une maison de santé sont
soutenu par le ministre donc par le
ministère de la Santé et par moi-même
c'està-dire qu'on se débrouille toujours
je me débrouille toujours pour
accompagner et pour qu'in finé le
dispositif puisse être efficient parce
que j'ai j'ai entendu longtemps oh il
faut des enclavés il faut que les gens
sortent de leur quartier il faut qu'ils
puissent mais enfin sauf que votre
collègue sénateur parlait de de mobilité
ben ça dépend où tu habites en fait ça
dépend où tu es alors c'est facile alors
vous imaginez une maman qui a un enfant
allez on prend l'autisme parce que c'est
probablement ce qui revient le plus elle
doit l'emmener le une heure de trajet
une heure pour revenir repartir mais moi
je suis plutôt pour une concentration
pour le médical au même endroit que une
des parents parce qu'on dit les mamans
il y a pas que les mamans les parents
puissent emmener leurs enfants chez le
pédiatre elles-même se faire soigner
parce qu'elles oublient le tr/art du
temps comme toute euh les maèirres de
famille évidemment de se soigner donc
sur 2025 2025 pardon j'envisage euh de
travailler beaucoup avec bien sûr des
parlementaires de tout bord pour
travailler un sur la santé mentale dans
les quartiers populaires je veux lancer
une mission euh pareil je pense que
c'est important de pouvoir l'évaluer de
pouvoir mieux le le diagnostiquer pour
mieux y répondre et
euh et monsieur le sénateur pour euh
pour le Gard le zonage je vous l'avais
dit tout à l'heure dans les dans les CR
dans les contrats de ville j'ai décidé
que 2,5 % du budget serait alloué à
l'accompagnement des quartiers
prioritaires qui sortent parce que ce
que j'ai vu en arrivant au ministère
mais je l'avais vu sur le terrain mais
je le vois mieux du ministère puisque
j'ai tous les chiffres les quartiers
prioritaires certains qui sont sortis
quelques années il y a quelques années
de manière brutale reviennent quelques
années après j'ai rien inventé euh donc
je dis il faut accompagner puisque il
concentre toujours les mêmes difficultés
sauf que la population a baissé c'est
une inepsie c'est une si on voudrait mal
faire on pourrait pas faire pire donc
j'ai décidé d'affecter 2 % et demi du
budget des contrats de ville sur la
compagnement des élus locaux qui doivent
sortir des quartiers prioritaires parce
que je disais a priori c'est une bonne
nouvelle quand on vous dit vous n'êtes
plus quartiers prioritaire non mais non
mais non je parle
intellectuellement non mais c'est pour
pour ça comme tout est relatif on sait
très bien que la baisse de population
est d à plein de choses à plein de
facteurs et que on ne peut pas laisser
des quartiers avec autant de difficultés
sortir de manière brutale et pour le
gare il me semble bien que les choses
ont été correctement faites vous me
l'accordez on a regardé cela avec
beaucoup d'attention donc chez vous tout
ça se tient beaucoup d'efforts ont été
fait merci de l'avoir rappelé parce que
comme je disais à à territoire trs en
difficulté moyen exceptionnel à louer
merci Jean-Luc breline Ren
garab le micro
Jean-Luc la ministre merci une question
qui demandera pas forcément une réponse
mais sur territoire
que j'ai dirigé avec mes amis depuis 25
ans 50000 habitants c'est donc pas tout
à fait les même sujet que que la ville
on a mis en place pour nos jeunes
l'apprentissage ça aujourd'hui dans tous
les métiers du bâtiment et on a pris en
charge le reste à charge pour nos
entreprises du cap et du brevet
professionnel et aujourd'hui en 4 ans
ces entreprises se sont tourné vers nous
on a signé 500 contrats d'apprentissage
500 contrats pour des jeunes de 15 à 18
ans pour un CP de plombier chauffagiste
maçon Plater électricien donc
aujourd'hui vous devez vous poser cette
question je pense madame la ministre
parce que l'apprentissage de nos métier
manuel moi je suis chef entreprise dans
une entreprise du bâtiment
l'apprentissage des Béti manuel devient
dramatique on l'a vu hier avec le
problème du bâtiment c'est une illusion
de pouvoir dire que demain matin on va
passer du G au f ou du f au e il n'y a
plus de compagnon et de compagnon formés
et là je me pose la question dans le
cadre de votre secrétariat d'État est-ce
que vous pourriez pas donner un coup de
main ou une impulsion pour que ces
jeunes dans nos territoires apprennent
un véritable métier qui va d'un Capp
d'un BP après un bac pro après un BTS
après un diplôme d'ingénieur parce qu'on
l'a chez moi dans l'entreprise j'ai
démarré avec des gamins de CRP qui ont
terminé ingénieur et ça aujourd'hui
c'est une vraie question sur lequelle
vous devez vous POS merci evveline Rena
garaban merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre en octobre dernier le
comité interministériel des villes a
prévu l'extension pour environ 9h par
semaine des horaires d'ouverture des
bibliothèques dans certains 500
quartiers l'état je ma question que je
me pose est-ce que l'État réellement mis
les moyens de sa politique dans le PLF
2024 pour assurer cette augmentation
alors pourquoi je vous pose cette
question parce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui que dans certaines
bibliothèques notamment à Nanterre qui
ont prévu cette extension il y a
aujourd'hui des grèves pour
notamment parler contre et dénoncer
l'augmentation des salaires qu'il y a
puisqu'il y a un manque très important
d'effectifs dans ces bibliothèques merci
de votre madame la ministre euh monsieur
le député
sur qu'est-ce que je viens de dire
député mon Dieu sénateur j'ai perdu
monsieur le sénateur je vous avais dit
que l'hémicycle me manquait non monsieur
le sénateur euh sur l'apprentissage
alors non seulement je suis en phase et
bravo pour vos chiffres parce que 500
contrats c'est énorme donc c'est pour ça
que le Président de la République il
l'avait annoncé lui-même une grande
réforme de l'apprentissage pourquoi pour
faire correspondre la réalité de nos
besoins
avec les les envies de nos jeunes sauf
que il y a une difficulté à tout ça vous
ne pouvez pas forcer des jeunes et vous
le savez mieux que moi à avoir une
vocation donc je pense qu'il faut ben
ouais une FO parce qu'une fois qu'on
aura fait la réforme et qu'on aura dit
voilà notre objectif et voilà les
moyens qu'on va allouer à cette réforme
sur l'apprentissage et dans les lycées
pro c'est que encore une fois on revient
sur 40 ans moi j'ai passé un bac
littéraire et à mon époque dans les
milieu des années 90 c'était bien
d'aller c'est formidable enfin les
enfants nous des quartiers prioritaire
très peu aller en lycée général beaucoup
aller en lycée pro sauf que c'est génial
d'aller en lycée pro quand on a envie de
faire un métier précis ou en CFA ou en
CFA non mais moi je alors je vais vous
dire je l'avais dit je je l'avais dit 10
fois j'ai été marine de beaucoup
beaucoup de promotion de jeunes dans des
fondations diverses et variées je disais
à chacun son iMAL AA
je peux pas mieux dire la réalité c'est
que les métiers du bâtiment dont vous
parlez sont en grande tension parce que
la difficulté du métier il faut essayer
de les emmener non le salaire le salaire
mais bon enfin on peut en parler mais en
tout cas ce qui est sûr vous pointez un
un un problème c'est un problème immense
auquel le président de la République a
décidé de répondre en lançant une grande
réforme de l'apprentissage dans les
lycées professionnels en concertation
évidemment avec les recteurs avec les
élus locaux évidemment c'est à la main
du Parlement et les entreprises et les
entreprises je pense que les entreprises
aussi ont un rôle à jouer sur la
promotion de leur de leur métier elles
jouent le jeu puisqu'elles ont besoin de
main d'œuvre euh et donc sur les les
madame la sénatrice
euh vous me disiez sur les les
bibliothèque ouverte le dimanche et
j'avais été alertée par la députée de
Nanterre sur les effets de grève euh
parce que il dénonçait un manque de
salaire ce que je crois et là ça
concerne la culture je pense que le
ministère de la Culture sur le droit
commun doit pouvoir accompagner cette
mesure parce que la généralisation ou
l'ouverture vous savez très bien que
c'est sur la base du volontariat on ne
peut pas obliger un maire à ouvrir sa
bibliothèque le dimanche et à faire
travailler euh c'estes euh les employés
municipaux je pense que c'est au-delà de
mon portefeuille politique de la ville
je pense qu'il y a une vraie
concertation une vraie réflexion à mener
avec le ministère de la Culture sur les
moyens déployés sur cette mesure qui est
une excellente mesure mais vous avez
raison il faut la il faut la quantifier
la mesurer et puisque les employés
municipaux et c'est normal travailler le
dimanche doit être payé deux fois plus
cher mais je crois que toutes les
municipalités le font doivent être
probablement un peu mieux payé pour les
motiver moi je suis ouverte à une pareil
à une concertation avec ma collègue Rima
abdoumak à la culture et avec tous les
élus locaux qui ont envie de se mettre
autour de la table pour généraliser
l'ouverture des bibliothèques le
dimanche alors merci l'heure avançant il
nous reste encore quelques questions et
je souhaiterais que vous puissiez les
poser donc si vous pouvez être
synthétique Lucien stanionne et Rémy
Cardon merci madame la présidente Madame
le Ministre au mois de mai dernier un
certain nombre de maires dans les
communes concernées par les quartiers
prioritaire ont lançé un cri d'alarme
concernant la la difficulté des familles
sur les questions aliment l'énergie
enfin et cetera j'aurais voulu savoir un
petit peu quelle était votre approche de
cette question là et puis deuxème point
rapidement concernant les les fonds
structurels
européens comment vous comptez les
mettre en œuvre sur le terrain de façon
concrète rapidement
oui je rebondis sur la question de mon
mon collègue vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de fait que il fallait une
évaluation travailler avec le Parlement
et cetera très bien alors qu'il y a des
des chiffres assez frappants depuis des
années et des années qui défilent à
chaque fois on sait que ces quartiers
prioritaires il y a 40 % de de moins de
25 ans on sait que la part des
collégiens et des lycéens appartenant à
une catégorie social défavorisé et de 60
% bref on sait que le taux de chômage
est supérieur à 2,7 en je rentre pas
dans le détail mais les chiffres sont là
madame la ministre de laine oui mais
c'est c'est énorme c'est énorme et donc
ma question est est très simple pourquoi
le le débat que vous avez aussi initié
après les émeutes à tourneré uniquement
c'est focalisé sur la question de la
sécurité ou parfois même sur la question
de l'uniforme dans les écoles et pas
justement sur ah bah écoutez je
excusez-moi je je rebondis sur vos vos
différents plateaux c'est pas parce que
BFM l'a dit que c'est vrai ou en tout
cas c'est les faits sont là donc ma
question est très simple c'est quoi le
plan en terme de politique structurelle
sur la santé sur l'éducation sur
l'emploi sur les questions de ces en
quelques minutes je pense que vous
pouvez
répondre un débat mais il serait temps
de attaquer on peut pas reporter à
chaque fois il faut que le Parlement
fasse de
l'évaluation monsieur le sénateur en
premier sur la mobilisation des fonds
européens je pense qu'on sur tous les
sujets qui nous concerne on a une
politique trop comment dire trop peu
alente beaucoup enfin donc on finance
beaucoup les politiques européennes et
on n'est pas selon les régions ça c'est
vous savez que les fonds européens sont
les régions je pense qu'on on peut faire
beaucoup mieux mais il faut beaucoup
d'accompagnement pour aller chercher ces
crédits qui nous reviennent qui nous
reviennent et qui qui ne sont qu'un
juste retour de ce que la France
investit dans l'Union européenne donc je
je propose et je l'ai déjà fait à
beaucoup d'associations d'élu de
travailler avec moi sur la mobilisation
des crédits européens sur euh sur nos
nos territoirees parce que voilà en
région Sud par exemple vous le savez
madame la Présidente pas la dernière
région à savoir aller les chercher donc
si on sait le faire là je pense que il y
a une méthodo ce sont des dossiers
complexes vous le savez donc à
dossierers complexe je pense qu'on on
doit mettre des moyens suffisant pour
être capable d'aller les chercher donc
ça
c'est la première chose euh monsieur le
député désolé monsieur le sénateur je
suis encore dans l'hémicycle euh ouais
c'est dur c'est dur dur vous parliez bon
les chiffres évidemment sont frappants
et je les connais aussi bien que vous
voilà je ne peux pas vous laisser dire
que j'ai résumé ou que le gouvernement
ou que la majorité a résumé les réponses
post émeut et au CIV uniquement à la
question sécurité je vous dis juste une
chose il ne faut jamais avoir mis ses
pieds je vais vous dire ce que moi je
pense et là je je regarde ni les fiches
ni les chiffres
et je vais vous répondre de manière
directe vous ne pouvez pas me dire à moi
que la sécurité n'est pas un sujet c'est
tout et quand vous dites vous avez
focalisé sur la tenue scolaire vous
m'excusez enfin j'ai répondu une fois à
une questions qu'on me poser je ne suis
pas responsable des questions qu'on me
pose et qu' en général quand on me sonne
je suis toujours au rendez-vous ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose il
me semble bien que dans le poste é meut
la première question la première
responsabilité de l'État c'était de
ramener l'ordre républicain vous êtes
d'accord avec moi bon quand vous vous
baladez comme moi de partout bon de quoi
vous parle les gens est-ce que les gens
viennent vous parler de la tenue
scolaire non les gens moi viennent me
parler les élus y compris et surtout les
élus de tous les bords je dis bien de
tous les bords je veux un commissariat
je veux plus de police municipale je
veux une police municipale qui a des
pouvoirs judiciaires je veux un
commissariat à tel endroit parce que là
pendant les émeutes si j'avais eu mon
commissariat je n'aurais j'aurais pu
répondre et j'aurais pu je veux de la
vidéo protection vous savez mieux que
moi si répondre à question non non non
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que les
moyens non mais après on peut non mais
je ben je peux pas en 3 minutes vous
répondre sur une politique globale là
vous pointez voilà vous pointez des
choses vous pointez des choses sur le le
chômage allez on va parler du chômage
oublions les quartiers allez oublions la
sécurité l'emploi on va parler de
l'emploi quartier 2030 donc il y a euh
et je vous donne on avait c'est le
président qui l'avait annoncé notamment
à Marseille de dire je crois aussi à
l'entrepreneuriat dans les quartiers
prioritaires et c'est à peu près 436
millions d'euros vous le savez affectés
par la BP pour permettre l'amorçage de
ceux qui ont envie de créer leur propre
entreprise petite moyenne ou grande
j'étais à H sousbois la semaine dernière
en fait il y a des choses remarquables
qui se font donc ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que la la la réponse ne peut
être que globale sur ça vous avez raison
mais vous ne pouvez pas dire je peux pas
vous laisser dire que sur les je ne peux
pas vous laisser dire que le
gouvernement a réduit uniquement à la
sécurité la sécurité éta la première des
réponses et le reste je vous invite à
discuter avec moi de toutes les mesures
CIV et si vous avez des propositions à
faire mes deux ministères sont ouverts
merci Sophie prima Michel bonus merci
beaucoup madame la présidente madame la
ministre d'abord je voudrais vous
remercier d'avoir tenu le Conseil
interministériel de la ville à Chantelou
les viges je voudrais vous dire que je
suis sénatrice des ivelim mais de ces
yvelin qui paye pas beaucoup
d'impôts c'est-à-dire du nord des
Yvelines dans un bassin industriel des
industrialisé dans lequel nous comptons
depuis la cité des Indes de Sartrouville
jusqu'à le valfouré de mant-eljolie cinq
communes en priorité en en ville
prioritaire priorité de la ville euh
politique de la ville pardon euh moi je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur la
réflexion que nous devons avoir sur la
définition de ces zones de prior de
politique de la ville parce que là dans
l'exemple précis dont je vous parle nous
avons effectivement des communes et à
juste titre qui sont en politique de la
ville et qui ont besoin d'être aidés et
la politique de la ville permet cette
aide mais nous avons tout un bassin en
réalité y compris des villes moyennes y
compris des villes qui font le travail
en matière de logements sociaux dans ma
commune l'ancienne commune dont j'étais
maire 42 % de logements sociaux villes
ouvrière autour de l'usine Renault de
Flin aujourd'hui en grande difficulté en
grande difficulté pourquoi parce qu'elle
ne bénéficie plus de la politique de la
ville que compte tenu des finances des
collectivités territoriales elle n'a
plus les moyens d'autofinancer des des
actions de politique de la ville et elle
est en train de tomber elle est en train
de tomber parce que elle est le le le je
sais pas comment dire ça élégamment mais
elle reçoit en tout cas toutes euh les
difficultés des communes de politique de
la ville que l'on est en train à juste
titre de remonter mais du coup tout tout
ce concentre là et on ne peut plus
accompagner et donc cette commune qui
était dans la politique de la ville qui
a été sortie dans la politique de la
ville euh est en train de devenir le
terreau des futurs des futurs alors je
vous remercie d'avoir mis les 2 et demi
% de la politique de la ville vers ces
communes là mais au-delà de ça c'est la
géographie qu'il faut interroger est-ce
qu'on n pas intérêt de raisonner en
terme de bassin de vie parce que notre
notre politique serait mieux mené me
semble-t-il dans la durée che bonus
merci
Sophie oui Sophie Sophie a un peu
anticipé ma question merci Madame
ministre je j'ai bien vu votre parcours
et dans les quartiersêtes passé je crois
que Fabien disait tout à l'heure mais on
est on est un peu un parcours un peu bon
dans les quartiers difficiles vous avez
parlé d'acteur de terrain et de zonage
et vous avez parlé de date j'ai entendu
le mois de décembre 2023 donc ça ve dire
demain ou pour le
zonage je
suislu conse départemental d'un canton
c'est un des de France aujourd'hui quand
on parle d'acteur de
terrain
qui personne connaît mieux que les élus
les acteurs de terrain on a grandi avec
eux on a on a leur le antériorité on a
travaillé dans les conseil d'école on a
fait lesassemblées nationale et ça
depuis 25 ans aujourd'hui les préfets je
respecte la fonction je respecte les
hommes ou les femmes qui sont qui sont à
la tête du département il y a pas de
problème mais n'oubliez pas les élus
n'oubliez pas les acteurs n'oubliez pas
les enseignants parce que aujourd'hui ce
fléchage là va être déterminant sur le
court le moyen et long terme ayons des
études d'impact et des conséquen de nos
décisions aussi parce que ça peut avoir
ça peut être bénéfique comme ça peut
être ça peut être voilà et la deuxième
chose c'est vous avez parlé de zone
franche zone franche urbaine et là aussi
c'est pareil anticipons parce que il y a
des investissements qui se font dans la
ville notamment le déplacement des
commerces notamment de relogement
d'habitants sur le court le moyen long
terme ne partons pas comme ça parce que
si on travaille pas ensemble dans la
main si on cré pas des passerelles
pardon on risque de de perdre énormément
voilà merci alors comme il reste deux
questions rapides si Henri Cabanel et
Annique jacqum veulent vite les poser de
façon à ce que la ministre réponde
globalement oui merci madame la
Présidente moi je vais vous parler de de
citoyenneté excusez-moi je suis arrivé
en retard j'avais un groupe de
travail sur le service civique le
service civique vous avez mis pas mal de
moyens les objectifs du du président de
la République était d'atteindre 200000
jeunes je ne sais je pense que
l'objectif n'a pas été atteint et
au-delà de ça
euh le service civicque ne concerne pas
suffisamment les jeunes engagés dans les
quartiers prioritaires il y a un très
faible pourcentage de ces jeunes qui
s'engagent dans les services civiques
donc la la question est simple que
pensez-vous faire pour
sensibiliser au mieux t ces jeunes qui
sont dans les quartiers difficiles pour
s'engager dans le service civique parce
que si il y a des jeunes qui doivent
s'engager dans la citoyenneté à travers
le service fivique c'est bien aussi en
priorité ces jeunes là Annique chacm
rapidement et la ministre fera une
réponse globale merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre j'ai vu
que vous étiez une femme de terrain très
pragmatique et pleine de bon sens donc
je pense que vous donnerez une une
réponse à ma question j'habite dans le
département du dou donc proche de
Besançon qui fait partie des trois
villes qui sont retenues pour les forces
action républicaine le phare donc une
question très précise qu'est-ce que vous
comptez mettre en place puisque on a
bien vu qu'on était retenu que ce plan
doit commencer début début 2024 donc
c'est c'est demain donc voilà de façon
très pratique comment est-ce que ça va
se réaliser et puis une deuxième
question très courte mon collègue l'a
déjà posé sur les leviers pour
responsabiliser les parents dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville et je
pense que c'est vraiment aussi
fondamental oui je disais la la façon de
responsabiliser les parents dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville vous
en avez en parti et madame la ministre a
déjà quand même largement répondu donc
une réponse globale madame la ministre
réponse
globale à tout vos questions merci
pardon merci à tous pour vos questions
donc pour vous
répondre 2 % et demi évidemment c'est je
sais que c'est pas suffisant et c'est
pour ça que sur quelques cas très
spécifiques avec j'ai demandé euh
l'autorisation à la première ministre
c'està-dire je prends le risque
politique de garder certains quartiers
qu'il est impossible en fait de faire
sortir c'est-à-dire que les les dégâts
euh les dégâts seraient tels que moi
j'en prendrai la responsabilité
c'estàdire je je peux pas prendre la
responsabilité de laisser tomber des
territoires pareils donc c'est regarder
au cas au cas par cas vraiment j'en ai
quatre qui peuvent même pas rentrer dans
les 2 et demi% que j'avais décidé
d'allouer euh donc voilà donc ça veut
dire qu'on va on va on pour
se voir juste derrière je je pense que
c'est un un ouais mais c'est un risque
politique en réalité minime c'est vous
savez tordre le coup parfois quelques
réglementations parce que la réalité
c'est que on a décidé de remonter le
nombre d'habitants parce pour pour des
raisons ENF lins fait très bien le
travail moi je je remets pas ça en cause
euh en revanche complètement d'accord
sur les bassins de vie évidemment que
c'est la la discussion je l'avais dit je
l'avais dit dès mon arrivée c'est
probablement la réflexion qu'on doit
avoir sur le zonage parce qu'une fois
que je je disais je veux je voudrais
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale pouvoir faire correspondre
l'éducation prioritaire donc l'éducation
nationale avec le zonage quartier
prioritaire une fois que je vous ai dit
ça on sait qu'il y aura encore des
écoles orphelines on sait sauf que moi
mon but c'est pas de faire calquer euh
zone sur zone c'est de dire je ne veux
plus d'école orpheline je ne veux plus
qu'il y ait une école quand tu traverses
la rue pour prendre l'expression de te
dire euh il ils accueillent un public
très difficile puisque avec toutes les
difficultés sociales qui peuvent exister
sur terre et de l'autre côté l'école
n'obtient aucun moyen donc ça c'est une
discussion au cas par cas que j'ai
ouverte je l'ai dit aux associations
d'élus dès mon arrivée donc on en
discutera sur les zones franches
urbaines euh merci madame la sénatrice
monsieur le sénateur euh ce que vous
dites évidemment est frappé au coin du
bon sens c'est pour ça que je une fois
qu'on a annoncé que j'ai annoncé que les
zones franches urbaines allaient être
continué sur l'année prochaine c'est pas
uniquement ça que j'ai dit j'ai dit on
va engager une discussion pour essayer
de faire quelque chose d'Efficient sur
le plan de la fiscalité dans nos
quartiers prioritaires donc c'est pas
une discussion que j'ai seu avec
moi-même c'est une discussion que j'ai
avec les élus locaux avec toutes les
associations et tous les parlementaires
qui ont envie de travailler sur le sujet
je l'avais annoncé donc si c'est un
sujet chez vous à Toulon et c'est si
c'est quelque chose sur laquelle sur
pardon quelque chose ouais sur laquelle
vous avez
euh envie de d'avancer avec moi ouais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on repense la
fiscalité dans nos quartiers
prioritaires mais je le ferai pas seul
puisque comme vous disiez qui mieux que
les élus connaissent leur territoire
donc moi je m'appuie beaucoup sur les
éluses dès que je je décide quelque
chose je consulte et ensemble on prend
la circulaire du 31 août de cette année
je l'ai pas décidé seul je l'ai
travailler avec ville et banlieu le
Conseil national des Villes enfin j'ai
j'ai consulté tout le monde et sur la
citoyenneté
euh euh oui le service civique
alors je me suis aperçu d'une chose en
arrivant à la citoyenneté beaucoup de
dispositifs et peu en réalité
connaissent les dispositifs donc on a un
énorme problème de faire savoir pourquoi
je disais je crois que vous êtes arrivés
un petit peu après dans les contrats de
ville je veux pouvoir mettre dans les
contrats de ville pour les outils
citoyennetés qui sont à ma disposition
avec les crédits qui vont avec donc je
pense que c'est pas parce que les jeunes
n'ont pas envie de faire un service
civique c'est parce qu'ils sont pas au
courant bah c'est un énorme problème
donc je pense qu'à
l'air allez 2023 2024 je pense qu'on
peut être capable la réalité c'est que
je vais beaucoup m'appuyer sur les
associations parce que c'est elles qui
connaissent les gens et énormément sur
les élus parce qu'ils connaissent leur
population beaucoup mieux que nous tous
réunis dans cette salle donc écoutez
j'espère n'avoir oublié personne madame
la présidente vous me dites non mais je
pense que vous avez largement répondu
aux questions de l'ensemble de nos
collègues je vous remercie je vous
remercie de votre Fran parler je vous
remercie également de votre dynamisme et
j'espère véritablement ben voilà que la
politique de la ville va prendre un
nouveau souffle merci beaucoup et bonne
journée
demander de reprendre